hello everyone and welcome to round four
of the 2018 candidates tournament now as
I've already mentioned it was a rest day
yesterday and it's always interesting
how a tournament will continue after a
rest day sometimes you will see just a
lot of draws but sometimes you'll see
fireworks all over the boards and here I
decided to show you a game between
Sergey kurakin and Levon Aronian as its
there are some other games still being
played but and until I see some results
I decided to show this one as it's
extremely interesting and I was I was
very very eager to see how our engine
would recover as after his loss the
chronics brilliancy /home preparation
that waited for two years for some
unlucky four player so let's see this
game Sergey has the white pieces and
like Aragon tried to surprise kramnik
here Sergey tries to surprise Aragon by
playing d4 and e4 is probably kurakin is
probably the most solid e4 player in
this field but he decides to go for d4
Knight to f6 we have c4 e6 Knight to f3
and d5 so the Queens gambit declined
Knight to c3 Bishop to b4 the rago's and
defense Bishop to g5 and now D captures
unci for the Vienna variation efore c5
now Bishop captures on c4 c capture son
d4 Knight captures and Bishop captures
on c3 be captures on c3 and Queen to a5
and this is a where the game really
starts now with this Queen - if I move
our engine is attacking the c3 pawn
threatening to capture with Czech also
there's an attack on the bishop on g5
and here Kerrigan has to decide what to
do basically black is kind of inviting
white to retreat with Bishop to d2 to
get rid of both threats but this leads
to an extremely sharp variation after
Knight captures on e4 Queen to g5 a
queen to g4 Knight captures only two and
now Queen captures on g7 attacking the
rook on h8 rook to f8 and now King kept
presently - and while it is possible to
play this obviously if Kerrigan was
offering it he was well prepared for it
another thing is after this Queen to a5
move you could go 9th to b5 as simply
with the idea that now the night is
blocking the Queen's attack to the
bishop on g5 and also the knight is
protecting the c3 pawn and after Knight
captures only for Queen to d4 again
attacking that g7 pawn here black can
castle seemingly giving up a d4 Knight
and after white captures now push a six
and white will have to give up this
night if he doesn't want to face Queen
captures on c3 well it's a simple it's a
perfectly fine position for both black
and white but after this Queen to a5
move it's hard to say was Sergei
certainly not prepared for this or
whatever but it's clear that Sergey did
spend a lot of time a lot more time and
has moved an iron on didn't his so here
Bishop to b5 by Sergei
this comes with check so Knight to d7
and now Bishop captures on f6 Queen
captures on c3 would check and King to
f1g captures on f6 as the night on d7 is
pinned and now h4 kurakin gives our and
on a taste of his own medicine here are
none plate Queen to b4 and for all of
the move is now our and still spent like
no time at all so this is still this was
still probably all all of it all of in
his home preparation and here Sergei
should definitely continue with this
plan of rope to h3 but this Queen to b4
move seems like it gives the correct you
know tempo so Cara can played rock to be
won but this actually gives Aragon a
very important score for the Queen here
Queen to d6 was played and now this is
much more important for black than if
for example rook to h3 was played
immediately so Cara can display it now
but now a6 simply offering hurricane a
choice do you want to get rid of your
Bishop for my knight or do you want to
retreat with the bishop and here Bishop
captures on d7 Bishop captures and rook
to d3
white is down upon but his position does
seem to be fine here after this a 6 move
hurricane played Bishop a back to e2 and
here Knight the c5 was played
and here you do have to take a lot of
things into consideration how do you how
do you prevent bad things from happening
here as our engine is spending no time
so you know that our engine is still in
his home preparation here your efore
point is attacked you know you're
already down one point so you could
defend it for example you could play
Bishop to Bishop to f3 if you play
Bishop to f3 you kind of lock out your
rockin h3 from entering the game also
you have to consider ideas like a5 that
attacks the knight also now the bishop
attacks the rockin h3
but after Knight to f5 the position
seems to be fine this does stop both
threats button and black and simply
exchange Queens and keep his extra pawn
with a very passive position for white
after rook captures of course but on the
other hand after this night to c5 move
you could also play rook to e3 but then
you have this nasty idea of Queen coming
all the way to all the way to h2 so
there really wouldn't be much to do here
but then again after Knight to f3 this
does seem to stop all the threats but I
think because Aragon was playing so fast
spending like no time at all
Sergei thought that this would
definitely not go his way
so after this night to c5 Sergei played
rook to c3 he decided to give up d4 pawn
and tried to seize the initiative here
Knight captures on e4 was played and now
rook to d3 lining up for the Queen and
the rook towards are against Queen on d6
and here again Aragon spent almost no
time he's simply castled here and it's
it's I mean it's definitely the case
that this was still in his home
preparation because Knight to c5 also
that seemed like an interesting move but
this actually runs into a lot of trouble
it seems like maybe you could force a
repetition from white but actually after
Knight to a5 you're in a whole lot of
trouble now we don't really have a lot
of squares for the Queen I move like
Quincy six runs into checkmate which
rope to d8 as the knight is covering d7
square and if you retreat with Queen to
c7 to guard checkmate
rook to c1 simply attacking this night
after b6 now you have Bishop to f3
attacking the rook and here black must
give up the rook if you play something
like rook to g8 you lose the game
Bishop to c6 check you can't grab the
bishop because of the same threat rope
to the 8th checkmate
after we block this simply rook captures
on d7 and it's all over
Knight captures simply worship to a4 and
now your queen is attacked from the rook
and whatever you play you can't go
anywhere like Queen to be 7 or a queen
to see it as 96 well we need the Queen
but you don't really have any other
choices Queen b7 and now you don't even
have to win the Queen you can even you
can play Knight to d6 winning the Queen
but you can even play Queen b6
threatening checkmate in one and after
he captures on f5 rook to e1 check King
d8 and now it's it's a force wind Queen
e7 checking c8 Bishop captures and now
you either capturing and face rook c1 or
King moves and then Roxy won't check
Queen has the block and then Bishop
captures on c6 this is checkmate so a
lot of deadly variations here that you
would have to consider but like I said
Aragon spent almost no time and he
castles here and here it's a circus time
to make a move he does have to justify
being down upon and it took him I think
over 30 minutes for his next move as now
you do you do have a free discovery so
can you make something of it no point to
jumping to the Queen side but you do
have to take into consideration what
about Knight to f5 if Knight to f5 yes
the queen is attacked now twice but then
Black has this idea of Queen to h2 with
the immediate threat of Queen to h1
checkmate and after we stop this for
example rook to h3 now black has Queen
to f4 with the threat of checkmate and
winning the night after white plays
Knight to e7 check removing the knight
from from threat King g7 and now rock to
f3 stopping checkmate now Knight to d2
checks the King forms both Brooks and
this is winning for black king moves
Knight captures and
after Queen captures it's a completely
winning position for black so here after
this castles by Aaron and it took
circuit like I said almost half an hour
more than half an hour and he played
Queen to see one I'm going for that nice
h6 square here Queen to e5 again almost
no time buyer none and now Bishop to f3
if this night that removes then the b7
pawn comes under attacked its attacked
twice by the rock and is Bishop and here
f5 again the strongest moved by black
and again took Aragon like no time
whatsoever Queen to h6 Sergei goes for
this as planned and now RN encounters
this again with the strongest move Queen
to f6 this going to h6 did have a lot of
poison to it well not a lot some poison
to it but again it just shows how
well-prepared our union is you can go
but should be seven with some bishops
exid has to simply develop your game
because Knight captures on f5 loses that
piece on d7 not loses a piece but loses
a pawn after black captures you can
simply capture the bishop on d7 another
thing if you play something like b5
would the idea of playing a bishop to a
very strong diagonal like like this one
then you lose the game immediately due
to Bishop captures on e4 and now you
can't capture with the Queen due to rock
the g3 you're getting checkmated and on
the other hand after you capture with
the pawn then Knight to c6 wins the game
as there is no square where the black
Queen can go to to still defend at the
g7 square as a rock to g3 is a terrible
threat so whatever you play here you
don't lose the queen or the game or both
so after Queen to h6 Queen to f6 again
strongest continuation by our Queen
captures Knight captures and now Sergei
wants to grab at least a pawn back so
Bishop captures Bishop captures rook
captures and now rope to c8 by Aragon so
after all of this skirmish in the middle
game now we reach an end game where
irony on it's up upon it's a double
death pawn but but still a pawn is upon
Rock to g3 check King moves and now rook
back
be three this rook to be three was was
the first start of surveys mistakes in
the endgame rook to e3 would have been
much better because of course you know
this Knight is coming to e4 and here
Sergei played rook to be 3 and now knife
to e4 was played but now this comes with
a temple of night to d2 check so again
Sergei must waste a move here
rook to be to and now rook F to d8
attacking the knight Knight moves and
now rook to d1 check so you can see the
skin is already in a lot of trouble
kingi - and now Knight the c3 check both
they're checking the King and defending
the rook on d1 we have king to e3 and
here rook King to g7 was played he won
and wants to protect his f7 pawn as he
considers there it's time to do this
although rook to e1 check or Knight to
d5 check were also possible immediately
trying to punish the white king but ok
King to g7 g3 Sergei also wants to
improve his position and here King to f6
again another idea other than bringing
the King into the game I was also a move
like a 5 simply cutting off the White
King and if he tries to escape rook g1
and now all of the squares around the
White King are covered almost all but it
will be very hard to play this for white
I like going through a field of
landmines
so after g3 King to f6 like we said and
now rook to a7 going for that a sex pawn
rook to c6 defending now King to f3 and
night the b5 attacking the rockin a7
rook moves and now e 5 King to g2 trying
to get some safety and now e4 here we
have a for kicking away that night from
b5 we have 90 to 83 and rook to d2 now
and this rook to d2 is the final moment
where Aaron really gets the momentum he
needs and it's very interesting how he
how he pulls it off here he plays rook
after Sundy to
Knight captures and e2 and now a move
that really really hurts white he plays
III
and I move like Knights the c2 to
prepare III doesn't isn't really working
because of night to f1 covering d3
square so he pushes III immediately and
now unfortunately you can't
unfortunately for Sergei you can't grab
it upon if you grab it then rook to c2
simply pinning the night if you defend
it then Knight to c4 with a double
attack on the pink piece the game is
over
so after e3 Knight to f3 and here rook
to c2 now pinning this F dupont as it's
attacked e to was also a possibility
simply pushing the past pawn and after
rook to e8 attacking rook to e6
defending captures captures and now nice
to e1 Sergei would have this defensive
resource because I prevents the black
from jumping to c2 with his Knight but
again then you have a king and g2 this
Knight is stuck here and this night will
will definitely win da for pawn so
probably also a winning position for
black but he goes for the strongest
continuation rook to c2 now rook
captures on a6 which check King moves
and night to d4 we have captures and
this sorry this night to d4 move was a
brilliant moment for for Aragon to
blunder the game away as it seems like e
two wins the game for black I mean you
either have to grab the pawn and lose a
piece or you have to capture the rook
and then for example captures captures
and then there's no way to stop
promotion but this would be a terrible
blunder because after this e to move Oh
Sergei would have Knight captures on f5
would check as you can see the rook is
cutting off the completely cutting off
the sixth rank in gas to move and now
locate is checkmate after black blocks
that would look as the knight is
covering a seven in g7 so this was a
nice opportunity to blunder the game but
he of course doesn't rook captures an f2
which check King to g1 and now Knight to
see to Aragon was the trade of that
night Knight captures rook captures and
King to f1 now rook to f2 check simply
forcing the King to e1 if
play King did you want then simply rook
to f3 wins the game there's no way to
stop this pawn if you attack the rooks e
- again you can't capture it because
black Queens rook to e6 is impossible
the f7 pawn is covering it
so after rook to have to check King do
you want and now Rock the g2 going for
those King side pawns rook to b6 and
this rock to b6 is the only move that
actually can maybe maybe maybe save the
game for white to some degree but you
know Aragon plays it very precisely rook
captures and g3 now rook to be for this
was the idea rook to b6 covering the DF
for square and here
rook - G - you can't go rook to g4 with
the idea of simply exchanging rooks
because now it's a white actually that's
winning after a 5 so Rock - G - rook to
f4 now again strongest King to g6 now
Luke to f3
rook to g4 rook captures rook captures
and here you don't have a way of
protecting your your h4 pawn there
there's really no no way to do it if
rook h3 simply king h5 so King to f2 now
rook captures RuPt d8 and here yup three
pawns in rocks and game is this morning
position of course it is is it winning
against Serbia kurakin today for some
reason called the Minister of Defence it
is if you play the correct moves and
it's interesting that if black didn't
have double F bonds if he only had like
an f1 in the nature 7 point then white
could draw this but with two doubled
pawns not not really and you'll see how
our a nun converts it rock to g4
now King f3 rub g7 rook to e5 King to
have six rock back to the e8 h v now
rook to e8 now King protects the pawn
king to f2 now rook to g5 King to f3 now
King to g7 rook has to move and now h4
King to f2 h 3 now rook to a3 attacking
the pawn now rock
behind the past on King to g1 teen to g6
and now King to h2 but now simply f4 and
because black has double deth phones
white can't grab this and and try to go
for a draw because white black will
always have an extra tempo simply by
pushing this pawn so rook to a7 f3 rope
to a 1 F 2 here rook to F 1 a rope to a
5 and now sir Aragon can even give up
the h3 pawn king captures King to g5
King to g3 and here after rook to f4
Sergei kurakin finally resigned the game
as there is really nothing he can do he
will either get check made it here on
the Kings side or or he will lose this
rook and then lose the endgame but yeah
a very interesting game and it's very
interesting how in this modern modern
chess and the age of engine preparation
it doesn't matter if Aragon loses the
game if he wins it if he draws the game
he always entertains so yeah a tough a
tough game for Sergei kirkin but you
know a nice boost of confidence 411
Oregon who like I said lost yesterday to
that kramnik brilliancy and now I
believe Aragon is up again to 50% in
this tournament and I can't show you the
standings as some games are still still
being played from round 4 but I will do
I think I'll do a video tomorrow morning
of one of the games from the candidate
so I will show you the standings then or
you can just check them online you know
so yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Jack
cliff as is double team atishoo
munitions or Umbraco which were
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon